Everyone being involved matters,
but if the leadership is not on board
and is not consistent
about talking about it,
living it, putting it into action,
it will not happen in the organization.
Celine Williams,
welcome to 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm wonderful, thank you.
I'm doing great.
Thank you very much.
I'm in Tel Aviv.
And where are you right now?
I'm in Toronto, Canada.
In Toronto, Canada.
And you know,
the one good thing that may happen
through this whole crisis,
is that I get to talk to people
from all over the world
in all sorts of weird hours.
I'm watching darkness,
you're watching the sunrise.
It's beautiful.
Celine,
executive coach,
founder of reVisionary,
vast experience
both in the entrepreneurial scene
in the tech ecosystem,
whether it's as a mentor,
business development,
culture coach, you name it.
I'd love to talk about leadership
and about the different challenges
that people face
and how to overcome them,
what we can learn from the pandemic
and what you've learned over
the past 20 years as a coach.
So, why don't you start off
by telling me a little bit
about yourself
and we'll get the ball
rolling from there.
Sure.
So, I'll tell you a little bit about
my journey, because as much
as I would love say,
I've been a coach for 20 years
since I came out of university,
that's not true.
But I've had a vast career.
I've done a lot of different things.
So, when I was actually in university,
I started my first business
that I always joke was like
the result of greed.
Basically, I didn't want to be making
seven dollars an hour
working in a retail store.
So, I started tutoring for a company
which I was making $25 an hour,
which when most people my age
were making seven,
I was like, this is great,
I'm rolling in money.
And then I found out
that they were charging students
50 or $75 an hour.
and I was like, hold on.
No, no, no, let me,
I'm just going to do this myself.
And so I started to tutor.
So I joke it was out of greed,
but it was really
an opportunity that I saw
that I have was I had a sort
of a specialty in tutoring.
So I was getting
a very specific group of kids
that were coming to me.
So, I was like,
why don't I leverage,
I can just do my own thing.
So, that's what I did.
So, you were talking to me about
making $25 an hour.
It's not about the greed.
It was about the opportunity
and about the curiosity.
continue the journey
from there, please.
Yeah.
So, I started my business
and then I ended up
creating a program.
It was at the time,
Basically it's so funny
because I look back
and when I talk to entrepreneurs
and when I'm mentoring,
I often use this story
even though it was 20ish years ago,
because I created a program
with a very specific niche of students
in mind, in a very specific need,
and I became known for that program.
So, when I moved to Montreal,
I ended up taking a corporate job,
which is I'll get into in a second.
I sold the IP for that program
because no one is doing it, right.
It's like, listen,
it was a tutoring program.
It's not like I was
making millions of dollars.
It was nothing.
But like I sold it
to another tutoring company
because I hadn't found a specific niche
created a solution
for a problem that they have
that no one had thought to do.
So, over the next few years,
this tutoring company used that for the,
and brought those students in there.
So, subconsciously, I guess,
unconsciously, I had done this thing
that we talked about
with entrepreneurs all the time.
We talk about
when you're running a startup,
when you're getting into business.
I just kind of done it accidentally
and it worked.
So, I did that
during one of the summers
before I moved to Montreal.
Probably two summers
I had a friend reach out and say,
hey, do you want a three month contract
at this company in health care
that had just gotten
a whole bunch of funding
from Health Canada
because it's socialized health.
Like we have universal health care here.
The government gave this company
tons of money.
It was this branch between,
it was in health informatics,
so between tech and health care.
And I was like, me,
23, 24 years old, whatever it was,
was like, I've never worked in an office,
that sounds great.
So, I took a three month contract
that lasted 11 years.
So, I was there for 11 years.
I did a number of different things.
I worked in HR for a bit.
I worked and changed,
a lot of the stuff I did
was people focused, right?
Change management,
I did stakeholder engagement,
communications.
I just kind of moved
every couple of years
to new areas.
Like I got a promotion
and moved to a different area,
which was great
for what I do now
because I got to touch a lot
of the people sides of the business.
Less on the tech side,
although I did project management,
which was the fun back and forth
between tech and business,
but I didn't actually do
any of the tech side,
but I got to be in that world.
So, Celine, I'm sorry.
For somebody that's coming
from the tech side
and knows practically nothing
about the HR side,
tell me a little bit about that.
Oh, well,
what I thought HR was,
was not what my HR experience was,
which is really interesting
in the work that I do now.
So, I was like really low level
when I was doing HR.
It was like HR coordinator stuff,
very general,
lots of stuff on benefits.
Like all the like very
transactional side of HR
is what I was doing.
And the company I worked for,
truth be told,
as much as their HR partner
wanted to be a partner,
they were very transactional.
It was not about culture.
It was not really about people.
It was about like, you know,
sign the contract, get the contract done,
here's your benefits,
make sure everyone has pencils,
i,t was that kind of thing.
So I did not, it was,
I did not like it
because I, you know,
the thing that I think
is great about HR is,
and I want to acknowledge this,
I fully recognize the benefits
and compensation,
and things like that
are an integral part of HR.
A hundred percent that matters.
However, if HR is really about humans,
if it's really about people,
if it's really about creating a system
that supports and empowers
and enables them,
then it has to be about culture
and it has to be about leadership
and it has to recognize those things.
And startups are
so much better at doing that
than sort of
more traditional companies are.
And this was a company
that was more of a startup
before they got the funding
and then got really bureaucratic.
So, very quickly I got out of that.
And I was like, this is not
this is not fun.
It's just paper pushing.
Is that a part of what then led
to your curiosity and passion
in regards to culture building
and leadership?
Yeah. It's 100%.
And when I left the company,
I'd already done training
to be an executive and business coach,
I very specifically done the training.
We went through a program
focused on that,
as opposed to something
like life coaching,
because that was not me,
but sort of executive business coaching
was definitely up my alley.
And in starting to work in that area
and looking for clients,
I started naturally,
I don't know if that's
the right word for it,
but I started attracting startups
In Toronto, in the ecosystem.
I won an entrepreneur award,
ended up in a co-working space
that had a lot of startups,
ended up working with a bunch of them.
I just kind of naturally
it started happening.
And culture was a thing
that I had been talking about
because my experience of culture
had been so crap.
So, I was more talking about it
from a don't do these things.
Right.
Like you can do culture intentionally,
culture by design,
you can do culture by design.
Here's some ideas I have
of what that looks like.
Here's some ideas of ways
you can make that real.
And they started hiring me
to actually implement it,
and actually work with them
at designing it.
And so, it was funny
because the thing
that I was passionate about,
because I had such a terrible experience
and with the note that I couldn't,
it took me years inside of corporate
to figure out what I didn't like.
Because I liked a lot of the people
that were on my team.
I was really lucky.
I had incredible leaders,
incredible leaders
that I worked directly for,
and wonderful teams that I worked on.
However,
I hated the experience of the company.
I hated the experience
of all of these other things.
And it was a culture thing
because they didn't really care.
They did say one thing, do another thing.
The leadership was out there
talking about something
and then doing something totally else,
totally different
inside the organization.
They'd change the,
my favorite example is
they were talking
about changing the mission,
something like that.
Mission-vision of the company.
They want to update it.
So, they got everyone in the company
into workshops to give their opinion.
And the statement that they went with
was the statement they came in
starting with.
Because they'd already made the decision.
They didn't actually care.
That's a terrible way to develop culture.
Because what you've said is,
we think you care about being involved,
but we don't care about your opinion.
So, after experiencing things
I was literally just talking about,
don't do these things.
And here's 25 examples of things
not to do that destroy your culture
once I became aware of the concept.
So, Celine before we continue,
because as a young entrepreneur myself,
that I'm very excited
to dive into my own venture
sooner rather than later.
A lot of my friends listening to this
are in their early stage startups,
what are some critical things
that we should not do
as we're building culture,
whether it's intentionally
or unintentionally?
What are some really like don'ts?
So, I think, you know,
it's going to sound so basic,
but don't say
you're going to do something
or don't say things are a certain way,
and then people have
a different experience of it.
I think that it's really easy to say,
if you're doing it intentionally,
it's really easy.
I'm going to talk about that
and I'll do unintentional second.
Right?
So, by design.
If you're a company,
you're starting a business
and you're saying,
here's what matters to us,
and here's what we stand for,
and here's what our values are,
and here's whatever
whatever that version of it is for you,
and those are all wonderful things to do.
However, if the people in your company
I don't care if there are five of them
or 500 of them,
if that is not
their actual lived experience,
you are undermining the culture
you are trying to build.
So, you cannot say it is one way
and then not have it be that way.
I work with large organizations right now
on making sure that if they're saying
these are their values,
this is the vision that they live by,
this is how they show up
at making sure going through
and that is the experience
of the vast majority of people,
and if it's one person's not experienced
it in a large company,
if that's not their experience
because they don't want it to be,
that's very different
than this entire team
is not operating in that way.
Right?
So, making sure that
that is aligned is really important.
I'm guessing
a classic example of that would be,
for example,
many companies today
love saying that they
support a bottom up innovation approach.
Right?
Now, the top people
of the pyramid would love
that the bottom layers
bubble up these ideas
and there is going to be people
that listen to them
and they're going to get heard.
And then sometimes,
when it comes to [--],
you have an idea
you go to your boss
and you get the door on your face
because it's not the KPI
that you were tasked to solve
by the end of the quarter.
So, speak to me in Christmas, right?
And that obviously something
that could very easily undermine
a culture in an organization.
Absolutely.
That's a great example of it.
Another one that I hear a lot is,
organizations say that they are,
that feedback matters to them.
Like whatever their version of,
we care about feedback,
we give feedback all around.
You know, we believe
in continuous improvement.
Feedback is a keep.
Agile organizations often talk about
feedback is really important.
And when you go to give feedback,
people don't listen to it.
People ignore it.
People have don't have
the tools to receive it.
They get defensive, whatever.
That undermines,
when that becomes systemic,
one person doing it
find that person you can,
they can get coached through
how to get better at receiving feedback.
There's lots of alternatives,
but when it becomes systemic,
you are undermining the culture
that you are purporting to be creating.
And so, that consistency,
I would actually use,
the term consistency
might be a better term
than what I used before,
but consistency inside of
what you're saying
and then what you're doing,
is probably the most toxic starting point
for what undermines cultures
as you are designing them.
And I would say that
if you're not doing culture by design,
you're allowing it to happen by default,
it's a little bit different.
Because if you're not saying
here's what we care about
as for our culture,
here's what we care about for leadership,
and it's kind of a free for all
the problem there becomes,
everyone is doing their own thing
and you get siloed, right?
You get silos inside the organization.
And this happens in
companies of 35 people.
It does not have to be
a large organization
to have communication that is siloed.
And the minute communication is siloed,
your culture cannot thrive.
It cannot because
you're not sharing information.
People don't know what's happening.
They only care about themselves.
It becomes
it's less of a first team mentality
and more of a protective not sharing.
And so it's different,
but it's just as toxic.
What has been incredibly successful
in building culture intentionally?
First and foremost, hands down,
it's getting all the leaders
on the same page.
If you have one leader
who cares about culture
and everyone else is just kind of
going along for it because they have to,
are going along with it,
going along for it.
Going along with it
because they have to,
nothing's going to happen.
It's not going to change.
It might,
while you're working with someone
or while it's the conversation topic,
people might be like,
yeah, let's do this thing.
But it doesn't filter down.
It doesn't trickle down.
It doesn't get to the people that are
going to be implementing it every day.
So, I when I started talking about,
and I want to be
really transparent about this,
when I started talking about culture,
I was like,
yeah, you need the leadership on board,
but it's not the only thing.
I have many more years
of experience now in this
and I 100% say this,
yes, everyone being involved matters.
But if the leadership is not on board
and is not consistent
about talking about it,
living it, putting it into action,
it will not happen in the organization.
It will not.
So, the most important thing is that
the leadership is actually
on the same page
and committed to the same things
when it comes to culture
and it comes to leadership.
And when that happens,
truly, and I've worked with
incredible organizations where
a new CEO came in or a new
for whatever reason,
their lens on culture was different,
they made the effort
to change the conversation
at their direct table level,
their leadership level,
and within a year,
the culture and organization
had transformed.
Wow.
And we're talking like
large organizations.
So, it's possible,
even if it wasn't a conversation before
and I want to acknowledge that
because it's never too late
to start this conversation as my point.
It's never too late
to start caring about culture.
But it definitely the leadership table
has to be committed to it
and care about it.
And this is what's so nice
about startups is that,
often the people
at the executive table,
at the leadership table are younger
and care about it more
because they're not used
to the way things were done
20 years ago.
So, it's a great opportunity to really,
really change the conversation
and get people on board.
It's so much easier
than someone who's been an executive
for 40 years who's like,
well, I've always done it this way.
I'm going to keep doing it this way.
So much easier to do it with startups.
Wow.
So, what do you get most excited about
when you are working as a coach today?
What I am most excited about?
I am really lucky
to get to do what I do.
And, you know, I want to start,
it sounds so cheesy,
but really I'm really lucky.
I love watching people
have a realization,
have a shift in their perspective.
Like, my company's tagline is,
shift your perspective,
because that's the thing that
the people I work with always say.
They're like, every time I talk to you,
I get a shift in perspective.
You show me a different way
of thinking about things.
And it's not about me being right
and saying this is the way to do it.
It's just that little shift
becomes a shift in behavior,
becomes a shift in something else.
And so, I love those moments
where people have that shift.
And I think the one of the biggest
one of the things that
I'm most excited about
and I get to work with people
is shifting them.
I'm going to use the word shift
800 times, apparently,
but shifting them out
of black and white thinking,
into grey thinking, if you will.
I love that. That's really great.
Thank you.
And really, so much of how we think
about things becomes black or white.
You know, I don't care if you are
if this is your first company
you've ever founded,
it's in its first year.
You're brand new
to building this business.
You're learning.
I guarantee you
you are operating 90% of the time
from black and white thinking.
And if you've been doing it for 40 years,
you're operating 95% of the time
from black and white thinking
because our brain loves certainty.
So, we create these structures.
And, you know, based on,
I was raised in a very unique way,
by very unique parents,
under very unique circumstances.
And I tend not to do
a lot of black and white thinking
naturally less than most people,
just because of the nature
of how I was raised.
And I have all the training now
and I've done so much work in it
that it's really,
I'm very quick to be like
or we could think about.
And people are always like that's
like just that helps a ton.
And I think those are things
that I love watching people
have that realization
that thing that they thought
was real and right and true
was just a construct in their brain.
And they get to change it
if they want to.
Celine, it's inspiring.
I love that thinking.
I'm an optimist by nature.
And I remember as a team leader
in various organizations
and one on the tech side,
the thing I hated most was when
somebody came to me and said,
Michael, we have a problem.
I always ask them to transition to,
Michael, we have an opportunity
for a solution.
They hated my guts for doing that
and annoyed the hell out of them.
But at the end it worked
because the whole shift in mindset
and understanding
that nothing is black and white.
There's always a scale
and you can always tilt the scale
and you'll never get
exactly what you want.
But it's somewhere there.
Celine, thank you for being
so generous with your time.
Before we leave, I have to ask you
the most difficult
and important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
So, first one I always use is curious.
Because I annoyingly ask
one million questions all the time.
So, I would say curious
is definitely one of them.
I would say I'm very earnest.
So, I don't love the word authentic
all the time
but I'm very earnest.
I believe in people.
I believe in being who I am
and kind of showing up that way.
Also probably
annoyingly for people in my life.
But, you know, it is what it is.
And I would say that
I think I would say courageous.
I would say courageous.
One of my values is courage.
And I tend to take things on
with no evidence
that they're necessarily going to work
and face things as they come
you know, from a place of optimism,
much like you, right.
Where it's like
I really trust that things
are going to work out,
and so I just step into it
and I have a lot of courage
in the face of the unknown.
So, I think I would use courage.
Right.
Thank you very much.
Celine, thank you very much.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
And continue helping people
become better leaders.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Michael.
It was lovely to chat with you.
I appreciate it.